>>Narrator:The world we live in contains greater
challenges and greater opportunities than
at any time in human history. While the global
financial crisis is impacting citizens and
families around the world, it's also prompting
government, companies and leaders to look
for fresh solutions.
This year at The World Economic Forum in Davos,
Switzerland, leading thinkers from all walks
of life will come together to examine solutions
to the problems we face and they want you
to be part of the discussion and have a chance
to attend Davos yourself; all expenses paid.
>> We just have to keep the hope alive.
>>Narrator: The theme for this year's forum
is "Shaping The Post-Crisis World."
>> Hello, You Tube.
>>Dominic Waray: Hello, You Tube. My name
is Dominic Waray and I'm head of environmental
initiatives at the world economic forum.
>>Maria Bartaroma: Hello, You Tube. I'm Maria
Bartaroma from CNBC.
>>Christiana Amanpour: I'm Christiana Amanpour
and I'm going to be at the world economic
forum in Davos, Switzerland January 29th.
>>Narrator: The leaders in Davos will be debating
key issues relating to the economy, the environment,
politics and ethics. You can join that debate
by voting on four basic questions posted on
YouTube.com/Davos. And you can go further.
Upload a video with your answer to one or
all of these questions The best video overall
will get to join the most influential people
in the world at Davos, all expenses paid.
>> The developed world needs to severely curb
our consumption of materials and energy.
>> Everyone got the wrong individual perspective
of how they sees things and how they see the
world.
>> It's very personal for me. It's not just
just political, it's not just public. I see
what's happening and we have to reverse it.
>>Narrator: So submit your video today. The
deadline is 20 January 2009.
Engage. Debate. Attend.
Have your say on the most pressing questions
at Davos at YouTube.com/Davos.